I've heard a lot of stories my friend
Troy lives in up in Vancouver and I was
asking him some questions about what he
knows about you and he goes I just know
that I've heard that the cast
has always really gotten along that they
all for the most part really like each
other is that is that honestly true
absolutely true it is true and we've
both been on shows where that's not the
case
I mean and still to get along we're
about to do all all this card right the
card season three coming back the
originals yes it's it's it's just
giddy about it I I feel as excited as I
did when uh first Contact was opening it
feels like that big a deal to me and I
know it's not and I know I shouldn't get
excited but the buzz and the uh
you know it's not supposed to be a
reunion but clearly it is a reunion I
mean yeah and and it's
I talked to Brent today today's Brent's
birthday happy birthday Brent Spiner and
uh he said oh there's birdie levar's
shooting Hawaii uh NCIS why so Lavar was
calling from Hawaii said yeah take
birdie I'm going up to Sea uh Michael he
said oh I love him he's a nice this is
Brent so again the third party
Brent's a great guest I mean you've
probably seen as how many years have you
been doing this since since Next
Generation 30 next generation is 36
years ago 35 36 so of all the movies you
directed two of the movies right they
were big Blockbusters right well they
made 150 million dollars yeah
I mean that's a big thing but you've
directed all these people many times
I have I mean do you ever have any
problems like does it ever get like a
family because we know families they
love each other and then they also go
get what
a [__] program why isn't that well
that can happen on the set I and then I
have to say it's you know let's figure
this [__] out right but um I generally
of I'm not a big confrontation guy right
so
if if they're if they're dug in on
something I said you know by all means
do it you know especially with lines
that we there used to be such sticklers
when we did next gen you had to do it
by the book every every line no
confidence and
and now
people have started people respect that
less which I think is a huge mistake
since the writers have been working on
these scripts for [__] months
sometimes years you got to give them the
respect to do them the way they're
written at least attempt to make that
come to life you can't change it
willy-nilly so the Kingsley that's
that's an issue I was trying to defend
the writers a little bit
but um
people misbehave sometimes because
they're tired because they're angry
about something at home well you know
yeah things happen things happen and and
and you try to compartmentalize it not
bring it to the set but [__] happens
should happen